my hair could be better in that [ __ ]
painting picture yeah my by the way I'm
getting my hair done today by my my
hairstylist Patrick and he goes um I go
I think I need a hair transplant I
another one and he goes I have the guy
can you imagine if I walk in here
without lids and a [ __ ] hole headed
over dude j-mo fight game [ __ ] why not
why not look great
game over be they gotta take my food I
said he has a guy to do it
this guy's good where did field go he
has a [ __ ] mullet dude Theo von he
got a hair transplant yeah multiple
times right why like this is same time
yeah yeah really it's the show one day
doing it yet blood he had like stubborn
boy wait so I didn't know I thought so
I'm sorry
that's not natural he has a full head of
hair at least not the all no no he says
it you use that guy feel like maybe
Anthony took something from the back
right he was before it even comes a
problem oh he's out of his mind he
wasn't losing his hair I don't know I've
never seen it here's your thing it might
be a wig is I don't know
get into the head I have no idea that
might be a wig I don't it's flawless the
same thing every time it's never changed
when doesn't bring him up let me look it
here I don't think so though that's an
old clip though a hair transplant he
talks about it obviously yeah I felt
yeah I'm not say anything he hasn't put
out there huh we get it
it's really always the same it's got
white hair to the sign but yeah it's
very very like unique I mean you got a
duck not unique what's the word here
looks good
organized yeah he has a strong uh
hairline yeah but where would where
would you go to get it done yeah you got
a different doctors watch it these days
right oh yeah is it that I take they
take they don't cut a piece out they
take strand
out of here they take the follicle here
and just put it here they do follicle
follow my wall you've been doing that
for everyone no they used to take they
take a strange sound like it cut a piece
out under a microscope didn't they take
it out now they just do it from here so
you know I'm seeing about doing a Papa I
don't know do you just get a wig
won't get a wig cuz I can yank on it but
I wouldn't mind getting uh but this is
the problem do can't be fifty to be
doing all this dumb [ __ ] just a fixture
here though well I'm an old man there so
we're the oldest thought oh the Chizzy
oldest there I mean by is the problem is
when I shave it's not a good look make
sure the gold or huh yeah alright are
you still shooting a [ __ ] show three
more episodes buddy boy three more
episodes
is there a bit mad yeah that's a great
picture right that's a great job that's
such a cool jacket I know I can't buy
one of those actually I want to wear it
oh yeah hey Chris send us your [ __ ]
jackets where we beat you up before you
get too upset [ __ ] well let's see how
answers I think would be Crispin lifted
into place thick - oh my god right now
with his weight dude I don't know why
you just don't get your hair done before
it's too late cuz what you don't like
it's isn't a hims commercial won't you
do it won't you realize it's gone it's
too late I know that's good right there
yeah sometimes I call him he doesn't
pick up and I just gonna text it says
makes me so mad yeah but you gotta get
your hair done dude um a honey hole get
off your [ __ ] fault
Whitney Cummings wheelchair dude yeah
but you like yours dude it's gonna be
stupid I don't want a low cost hair
plant I want the best hairdo do you
think I need to go in there no I'm not
gonna [ __ ] found y'all that that's not
cool to you and it has to be a really
good hair look that could be you like
you Lee that's your top left you're a
little worse let's be honest and then
look at his on the bottom mm-hmm guy on
the right Jesus that's amazing
what from dictates that mister steal
your girl yes oh that's him celebrity
hairstylist wait Wow I'm not let that
guy touch my foot that guy noise made me
- don't touch me he looks getting weird
sanity's it's got eyes lips it's the
whole thing's a weird you know patchy
because this Chester
dudes with beads there's a lot off I
don't trust guys with beads
I don't you've got a guy whereby don't
[ __ ] music weird I agree with you who
that's transgender look at him
who's transgender services what can you
do a file if I'm a transgender oh my god
Oh interesting
Wow unbelievable okay well I don't
anybody who's that much of a marketer no
no well you separate yourself
I now are they good artists can't have
just a director to experience this for
huh let's do it before it's too late
though let's just see how it goes I'll
bring you in and when they gonna clone
here come on I've been waiting see how
far away they are from [ __ ] cloning
hair always look what the Piven did ah
probably a hair transplant I mean
probably traditionalism has to be that
one of the best used to play you know
you say George Costanza on Seinfeld you
still wall yeah huh
yeah we're using stem cells were first
baldness and it's actually well let's go
yeah baldness man it's tough in it I
mean yeah it's annoying soon there will
be unlimited hair new use of stem cells
and 3d printing could make baldness of
obsolete for the wealthy all right well
I make money and I would spend I'd spent
a lot of money for a good full head of
hair how much would I spent I spent a
lot of money
well like what's it like be serious I'll
regret yeah that's fair right here I'd
spend a hug gotta keep my head right I
just thought that's the number hundo
[ __ ] off god I have to do it that's the
whole sentence never doing 100%
no you know what [ __ ] it yeah that make
payment to have great hair put me on a
layaway [ __ ] off 100% mm-hmm tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]